I'm film resumes beautiful welcome back
to our lovely beautiful super girlfriend
hey where is here
really she's always this dumb don't even
worry about it
I am in oh there I am a red bird secret
hoop yes is everyone knows that please
everyone knows the Bird red bird secret
how are you
approved air how are you how are you I'm
good now that you're here guide net ela
why the swinglish why dude why are you
not good that's not what I said woman do
you speak Swedish the speak Swedish how
are you bad to the bone she pissed me
off
how are you bad what kind of answer is
that true that by stupid hashtag eva is
a [ __ ]
what are mini-com in the eggs i ask
myself that every day it'd be great if
we could have a conversation
let's ask something serious about her I
don't know let's think here are you part
of one direction
I hate one direction
we're done I'm not talking to you
anymore
I need Cuddy Matt I remember why I don't
do this anymore
no slash hates one direction it's no
slash hates oh so you don't hate one
direction why / why do you hate them
you're so cool
you have everything why would you hate
let's ask her something better do you
like yes I like video games
why do you yes I like video games
she thinks I'm a video game great why do
you like Buddha pie they kiss your cuz
you're kind and gentle you are forgiven
this pretty pie I like you okay
I do not like you either we're heading
it up so well don't you smile at me beer
oh you an alcoholic with I guess a I
never can no know why cuz bugs out god
she pissed me off
make me oh I will make you shut up
bazooka gun what deaf [ __ ] Dargis
bazooka missile projector this [ __ ]
knows everything also dildo destroy you
who's out tank destroyer destroyer Jesus
Christ she knows all the cool tricks so
if you just add destroyer to it you're
good you're good
pulls out chuck norris destroyer now why
would you destroy tech norris that is
just ridiculous calls out chuck norris
destroyer makes out with it Chuck Norris
while playing birdy pulls out anti anti
Chuck Norris this this woman it's a
criminal mastermind you're a terrorist a
Muay pulls out what a dump well now why
would you go there we were just playing
around now you where the [ __ ] is Bob the
dumpster Bob the dumpster okay
that's cool pulls out the entire Klingon
feet stop falling
[ __ ] out where did she pull them out
from pulls out millennium shield da
pulls out unicorn a slayer ultra what do
you want from me where there's all these
things come from your rectum now well
what's alexandre dumas doing there what
kind of business would he possibly have
inside your anus stops you from pulling
[ __ ] out you're gonna pull muscle pulls
out nothing she always wins now you owe
now I'm being Roman Britney Spears isn't
a food Britney Spears you're absolutely
right
can't believe I've been so blind all my
life Bodie
booty booty booty booty woody I like you
works every time maybe booty can be are
always I have a question a question that
I've been wanting to ask for a long time
why do I never see any baby pigeons so
do you want a boyfriend don't ask me
that right now I want to know about the
baby pigeons can I be your boyfriend
that is so weird that I don't even wanna
don't dodge the question why do I never
see baby pigeons can I be your
girlfriend and stop flirting with me
please let me be your girlfriend what
about the baby pigeons answer me about
two baby pigeons and then we could talk
okay I want to be your slave
now I want you to be my master wait a
minute
who is the leader of Illuminati UNCA